Land und
[Musik]
Precht schönen guten Morgen Richard
guten Morgen Markus woerreiche ich dich
wie immer in der kinate du arbeitest du
denkst ich versuche es finde es gelingt
gelingt dir sehr sehr häufig möchte ich
sagen und das meine ich voller voller
Lob und Respekt und Anerkennung Richard
ich habe
das Gefühl wir sind den Leuten was
schuldig und zwar werde ich immer wieder
darauf angesprochen wann macht ihr
endlich mal den zweiten Teil der
Todsünden das hat die Leute irgendwie
interessiert und fasziniert und
getriggert und ich habe einen schönen
Satz für dich für den Einstieg die
sieben Todsünden haben in der Welt nicht
so viel Böses angerichtet wie die sieben
todtug den von von Bernhard Shaw und ich
finde das ein sehr sehr guter Satz ja ja
also ich denke zumindestens sagen wir
mal die Kehrseite der Todsünden der
Moralismus ist ja im Prinzip selber ab
einem bestimmten Ausmaß eine Todsünde ne
und ich denke das war das was SH damit
auch zum Ausdruck bringen sollte
alsozusagen die Prediger des reinen und
des waren und so weiter die haben
natürlich tatsächlich in ihrem Leben
sehr sehr viel Unheil angerichtet ne man
denke auch an an die
Kreuzzüge oder man man man denke an
puritanischen gesinnungsterror und so
weiter also da ist natürlich was dran ne
also irgendwie besteht ja der Reiz des
Lebens darin dass man zwischen den
Todsünden auf im einem Pol und den
Tugenden auf der anderen Seite irgendwo
eine Balance findet weil ein völliges
Leben im einen wie im anderen ist weder
möglich noch
wünschenswert das das finde ich
tatsächlich auch ja die sieben
todssünden von denen wir gesagt haben
damals wenn ich mich richtig erinnere
das ist sozusagen ja sind so im Grunde
die Leitplanken so ein bisschen für ein
gelungenes Leben eine eine
Bedienungsanleitung für das Leben für
den Einzelnen und wenn man sich ein
bisschen versucht daran zu halten obwohl
das ein sehr altes Konzept ist ja und
man sagen könnte oh mein Gott was haben
wir denn im Jahr 2023 damit zu tun es
ist interessant wie die Reaktion der
Leute darauf war weil wir alle spüren da
geht es genau um Dinge nicht um die zehn
Gebote sondern um die sieben totsü es
geht um Dinge die uns alle nicht fremd
sind wir haben letztes mal gesprochen
über night wir haben über gear
gesprochen mhm äh eine weitere todsunde
über die wir gar nicht gesprochen haben
ist Trägheit mhm ja also das
Wirtschaftswunder der 50er Jahre z.B ja
das
zumindest in Deutschland jedem ein
Kühlschrank ein Fernseher und sehr viel
Gemütlichkeit letztenendes auch gebracht
hat ist äh das Wunder das sozusagen
möglich war weil wir nicht träge waren
ja und ich
würde sagen es gibt einen Zusammenhang
zwischen dem Erfolg von damals und einem
Gefühl dass heute viele äußern sagen
aber jetzt sind wir so träge geworden
weil wir uns auf diesem Wohlstand ein
Biss ermal war damals alles kaputt ne da
wird man schon mal sehr viel aktiver als
in den heutigen Zeiten und zweitens gab
gab es die direkte Belohnung das das war
ja die die Zeit des Wirtschaftswunders
war ja auch die Zeit des kollektiven
Aufstiegs ne also in den Ende der 50er
Jahre ging es den Menschen ja besser als
ihn 10 20 Jahre vorher gegangen ist
richtig das heißt also man sah ja auch
die unglaublichen Erfolge durch die
Früchte seiner Arbeit es gab die große
aufstiegserzählung dann erst recht in
den 60er Jahren als die Kinder von
Handwerkern die Gelegenheit hatten
Ingenieure zu werden oder Lehrer und so
weiter die ersten Akademiker ihrer
Familie zu werden in einem ganz ganz
großen breiten Ausmaß und das alles war
natürlich ein Feuer was die Tüchtigkeit
auch immer weiter angefacht hat ne wenn
du lohnende Ziele vor Augen siehst wenn
es was zu tun gibt äh wenn wenn quasi
alle anpacken und äh wenn das Hauptziel
darum besteht eigentlich sich aus einer
zumindest ein relativen Armut zu befeien
und sozial aufzusteigen dann wirst du
selten unter solchen Bedingungen träge
Gesellschaften finden ne wir würden die
chinesische Gesellschaft weil der ein
bisschen ähnlich ist wie bei uns in 50er
60er Jahren ja die empfinden wir eben
auch als eine sehr tüchtige Gesellschaft
also es gibt kommt ja auch immer auf die
Rahmenbedingungen an nicht so sehr auf
die nationalen Mentalitäten als auf die
Rahmenbedingung wie tüchtig Menschen
sind das hängt von den Umständen sehr
stark ab und von dem was die anderen tun
genau und mirner Funk Kollegin von der
Welt sagt dieses Wirtschaftswunder der
50er Jahre hat eine Trägheit ausgelöst
die wir in Wahrheit bis heute nicht mehr
überwunden haben und deswegen ist unser
Abstieg quasi auf unaufhaltsam ja das
gefällt mir nicht so sehr weil es ein
bisschen gegen das redet was ich gerade
gesagt habe es psychologisiert mir zu
platt weil ich der Grund warum die
Menschen heute andere Ansprüche stellen
als in den 50er 60er Jahren ne mit den
ganz langen Arbeitszeiten ne und das
dauerte noch ewig bis die Gewerkschaften
dann den freien Samstag da für Arbeiter
erkämpft haben und so also das war eine
völlig andere Zeit und Menschen sind in
ihrem Verhalten Kinder ihrer Zeit und
wenn wir heute eine Zeit haben in der es
möglich ist gut über die Runden zu
kommen mit deutlich weniger Arbeit in
der die Ansprüche an das Glück enorm
gestiegen sind wo es nicht in erster
Linie darauskommt sich aus der Armut zu
befreien s für sehr viele Menschen
einfach darum geht ein möglichst
erfülltes glückliches Leben gemäß ihren
Anlagen und Neigungen zu führen den das
ist ein ganz natürlicher Prozess dass
das ETOS ETOS der Arbeitsgesellschaft in
dieser Form nicht erhalten bleibt denn
das was wir hier erleben also die ich
nenne das ja immer die sinngesellschaft
das ist ja nicht etwas typisch deutsches
ne also diese gleichen Ansprüche finden
sich auch bei der jungen französischen
Jugend oder in vielen Regionen in den
USA und sie finden sich in Italien und
in Spanien und so das ist ja eine
kollektive Veränderung die deswegen
erfolgt ist weil sie möglich ist also
ich meine wenn man davon Glück und
selbstverung den 50er 60er Jen weil wir
un man kann sogar sagen bis zu einem
gewissen gerade leisten können
vielleicht nicht in dem Ausmaß aber in
der strukturellen Tendenz können wir uns
das leisten und irgendwann werden all
die hochautomatisierten Computersysteme
die wir haben und die Robotik unds auch
noch sehr viel mehr unangenehme vor
allenen geistig langweilige Arbeit
abnehmen und im gleichen Maße werden die
Menschen noch mehr Zeit für sich haben
und die richtigen Dinge zu machen und
diese Ansprüche die sind alle schon da
worunter wir heute leiden ist das
mismatch auf der einen Seite haben sind
die Ansprüche heute bereits so als ob
die Computer und die Roboter für uns
fast alles erledigen so hoch sind
inzwischen die Ansprüche und auf der
anderen Seite haben wir aber noch genug
arbeiten die keiner machen will und die
auch nicht von Robotern und Computern
gemacht werden das heißt wir haben so
eine Asymmetrie die das bewus sein der
Menschen im Hinblick auf eine
sinngesellschaft ist schneller
vorangeschritten als die Arbeitswelt
sich strukturell verändert hat
interessanter gedke die Diagnose der
gegenwärtigen Lage TR ist das für dich
ein Thema ich ich erlebe dich immer als
wahnsinnig fleißig in sehr viel
arbeitenden Menschen also den Begriff
Fleiß lehne ich für mich in ganzer Linie
ab wirklich ich bin kein fleißiger
Mensch ne doch ne ne fleißig sind für
mich Menschen deren über ich ja sie
antreibt und antreibt und die alle
arbeiten egal was sie sind sofort
erledigen und das ist bei mir nicht der
Fall na bei mir auch nicht aber ich k
alle fleißigen Menschen die ich kenne
sagen sie sein keine fleißigen Menschen
ja aber zu Fleiß gehört auch also dazu
dass man Dinge die man nicht gerne macht
ja schnell und gewissenhaft erledigt das
ist für mich Definition von flei das ist
einfach nur clever den den den Mist den
man nicht machen will die steuerbelege
z.B einfach schon im Januar sauber
einzusammeln dann hast du im November
kein Stress genau und das nimmt man sich
jeden januar vor und am Ende bleibt
alles im Dezember liegen das ist bei mir
auch so und das ist bei mir auch also
Sachen die ich nicht gerne mache bleiben
schon mal ziemlich lange liegen ich bin
auch kein akribischer Beantworter von
E-Mails und smsen da könnt schon mal
Tage oder Wochen ins Land schreiten bis
ich sag so jetzt arbeite ich mal 50 am
Stück oder so ab fleißige Menschen
erledigen das immer gleich und sofort du
kannst das clever nennen aber die werden
offensichtlich nicht durch die Todsünde
der Trägheit da belastet ich könnte noch
ein anderes Argument bringen der
Hauptgrund warum ich das alles nicht
mache ist weil ich mit Gedanken woanders
bin wenn man verreißt Kopf verrei Kopf
verreißt also wenn du ein Buch schreibst
ja oder ein anderen größeren Projekt
oder eine Messe arbeitest oder was auch
immer dann bin ich als
Hochbegabter monotasker ja nur dort nur
dort und nirgendwo sonst das heißt also
ich bringe mein Gehirn komplett in eine
andere Welt und dann kannst du dir nicht
vorstellen wie sich in kürzester Zeit
ungeöffnete Post bei mir stapelt und
unbeantwortete E-Mails einander jagen
und so weiter und so weiter weil ich
mich einfach nicht auf mehreres
gleichzeitig konzentrieren kann und das
ist dann im im Endeffekt hat das schon
eine gewisse Trägheit weil wenn Sachen
so lange liegen bleiben bis es
dramatisch wird dann ist das nicht
förderlich und fleißigen Menschen
passiert sowas nicht ja ich würde sagen
du setzt einfach andere Akzente
vielleicht ist das eher das Thema nee
das ist zu diplomatisch formuliert ich
war schon in der Schule nicht fleißig
also wo ich keine richtige Lust zu hatte
habe ich auch nur das All
nototdürftigste erledigt oder gar nichts
gemacht oder so ja oder schon mal
Hausaufgaben in irgendwelchen Fächern
wochenlang nicht gemacht und das machen
fleißige Menschen nicht also ich ich
habe schon früh gelernt dass ich nicht
zu den fleißigen Menschen gehöre mm ja
flei ich merke das gerade du definierst
flei eher als Disziplin und und für mich
ist das diszipliniert ne wenn wenn
Menschen sauber ihre steuerbelege
sammeln und ich kenne Leute die die
sagen z.B alles was unangenehm ist mache
ich vor 12 12 Uhr ich stehe auf und fang
direkt damit an das halte ich für ein
riesen Fehler aus meiner Sicht meine
meine mit Abstand größte
Arbeitsproduktivität ist morgens ja also
ich kreative Dinge wie schreiben mache
ich morgens ja also wenn man quasi noch
noch mit einem unverbrauchten frischen
Gehirn nach einem hoffentlich guten
Schlaf sich an den Schreibtisch setzt ja
dann
ist klar ein Kaffee noch zum dopen und
so ja und dann läuft das wenn ich di
wertvolle Zeit jetzt damit zubringen
würde ja mich mich um
Steuerangelegenheiten zu kümmern oder um
um andere Lästigkeiten die man Regeln
muss dann wäre ich müde bevor ich mit
der richtigen Arbeit anfange also sage
ich mir das mache ich heute Abend aber
wenn man den ganzen Tag gearbeitet hat
und abends ein Glas Rotwein trinkt dann
ist das letzte worauf man Lust hat ja
die Steuerklärung Steuerklärung
verbringt man mit lieben Menschen seine
Zeit und nicht damit und so geht das
dann von Tag zu Tag und dann ist schon
wieder Dezember ja dann ist schon wieder
der nächste Morgen wo man wieder
kreative arbeiten macht und irgendwann
ist Dezember genau so genau und das ist
doch das ist doch schön dass es dass es
Dinge gibt die einfach immer gleich Blei
das bei dir also bist du gehörst du zu
diesen disziplinierten Menschen die ganz
früh aufstehen und morgens alle lästigen
Arbeiten erledigen
nein ich manchmal mache ich das manchmal
fällt mir das ein dass das ein gutes
Konzept ist ich halte das wirklich für
ein gutes Konzept weil dann hast du es
weg du hast die Gedanken aus dem Kopf ja
du hast es einfach erledigt das ist
super aber ich schaff es häufig nicht
und ich würde Michel auch tatsächlich
nicht für einen fleißigen Menschen
halten ich werde eher zum Fleiß
gezwungen wenn man so will
andererseits ich habe immer den Fleiß
und die wahnsinnige Disziplin meiner
Mutter z.B wirklich bewundert ja die hat
uns unter sehr schwierigen Umständen mit
einer ungeheuren Selbstdisziplin und und
und Selbstaufgabe auch wirklich einfach
durchgebracht und das hat mich natürlich
wahnsinnig geprägt und das ist auch
einer der Gründe warum
ich aus Verantwortung heraus ja ja und
ja richtig aber weißt es gibt einen
riesigen
Unterschied wenn wenn du sagen würdest
ich bin fleißig ja also ich jetzt weil
ich weil ich auch relativ viel arbeite
so gibt's trotzdem einen riesigen
Unterschied zwischen meinem
vermeintlichen Fleiß und dem Fleiß
meiner Mutter mein Fleiß den ich so auch
wie du nicht bezeichnen würde ich sitze
auch gerne einfach mal auf einer Wiese
und schaue doof in in die Luft ähm dann
würde ich immer sagen das ist aber ein
flei der den habe ich mir selber
ausgesucht meine Mutter hatte keine Wahl
das ist etwas völlig anderes und das ist
das was unvorstellbar ermüdend ist
wenn du wenn du ständig von außen
sozusagen diktiert bekommst was du zu
tun hast und das ist auch glaube ich das
wo Menschen sich dann häufig irgendwann
verlieren oder auch in die Depression
rutschen z.B weil es weil es wahnsinnig
schwer ist wenn du immer das Gefühl hast
nicht du sitzt auf dem Kutschbock und
sagst wo es lang geht sondern das Leben
andere die Umstände sagen dir ständig
was du jetzt als nächstes abzuliefern
hast und vor dieser Art von Fleis und
und Selbstdisziplin daran nicht zu
zerbrechen daavür habe ich tatsächlich
großen Respekt weil das erfordert
ungeheure Kraft und das meine meine
kleine zarte Mutter hat das mit mit
bewundernswerter Geduld durchgezogen das
hat mir keiner vorgelebt das war bei uns
zu Hause anders also wir waren ja auch
viele Kinder aber wenn meine Mutter
keine Lust hatte dann gab es auch schon
mal kein Mittagessen also das war jetzt
nicht das bedingungslose aufopfern für
die Familie und was mein Vater anbelangt
da habe ich eine sehr unangenehme
Angewohnheit übernommen also wenn dann
z.B irgendwo eine Glühbirne kaputt war
ja mein Vater sah das als sagen wir mal
Schicksalsschlag ja also dachte jetzt
nicht dass es an ihm ist da jetzt sofort
irgendwas zu ändern ja dann konnte schon
mal in dem Flur wochenlang die Lampe
eben nicht brennen ja weil es ist auch
mal interessant wie das dann so ist weiß
du wenn der Flur dunkel ist fühlt er
sich anders an dann sieht er anders
aus und das geht mir auch genauso also
wenn so technische Dinge kaputt gehen
dass ich dann of denke a ist interessant
man kann auch im Dunkeln kommt man diese
Treppe hoch oder so ja statt einfach mal
einfach mal die Birne auszuwechseln und
ich kann natürlich sagen das macht das
Zusammenleben mit mir durchaus
anstrengend ich will nicht sagen dass
ich das nie mache und wenn ich dann die
Birne gewechselt habe bin ich auch stolz
ich meine die Birne ist jetzt ein
einfaches Beispiel es gibt ja auch
kompliziertere Sachen die man zu lösen
hat oder handwerkliche Dinge und wenn
ich handwerklich was gut hingekriegt
habe kann ich mich gar nicht drüber
beruhigen vor Freude ja ist ein viel
schöneres Gefühl als ein Text
geschrieben zu haben aber der Angang
dazu
das gehört wirklich zu den Dingen die
ich sehr sehr gerne und sehr regelmäßig
verschiebe und und nur eine private
Frage was mich interessiert verlangst du
dann auch ausführlich gelobt zu werden
nee nee nee ich bin auch mit Selbstlob
ganz gut also nee nee ich freue mich
dann einfach über mich selber ja also
ich muss das jetzt nicht jedben zeigen
und sagen guck mal wie ich dieses Reg
hier angebracht hab oder was ich jetzt
irgendwie großartiges gemacht habe nee
nee aber die die Freude über mich selber
weil ich finde das immer so
unwahrscheinlich dass mir das gelingt
weiß es gibt ja Männer die wissen es
gibt keine handwerkliche Aufgabe der sie
nicht gewachsen sind und ich denke bei
vielen handwerklichen Aufgaben oh Gott
ich probiere das jetzt mal obwohl ich
den bestimmt nicht gewachsen bin und
wenn man es dann trotzdem geschafft hat
und wenn es dann gut geworden ist große
innere Freude ja super ja das ist Demut
weißt du das eine Tugend die du de in
Wahrheit mitbringst
apropos Demut und und und Selbstlob
Richard führt uns direkt zu einer wie
ich finde sehr wichtigen toz der Hochmut
Eitelkeit Selbstliebe schöner Satz
Theodor Fontane manche Hähne glauben
dass die Sonne ihretwgen auf geht genau
ganz berühmter Satz ja ich finde das
Thema interessant weil ich nehme mal an
dass das diejenige Todsünde ist die uns
von außen am häufigsten vorgeworfen wird
mm Hochmut Eitelkeit ja dir und mir also
ich glaube da sitzen wir im selben ja ja
da sitzen wir glaube ich an wen hast du
den sonst bei uns
gedacht nee aber ich denke man dass man
so dass man das so dass man das so von
außen weißt du wenn man wenn man so eine
Rampensau ist und wenn man entsprechend
in der Öffentlichkeit steht ja
und na ja dann liegt das irgendwie nahe
dass das so ist was man mit Menschen
verbindet und sagt das die sind eitle
fatzkes und die hören sie hören sich
gern reden und alles was damit so
zusammenhängt deswegen würde mich mal
interessieren was würdest du dir selber
für eine Schulnote geben Thema Hochmut
schwer man man wenn man jetzt sagen
würde eins wäre das ja genau das ne das
wäre genau das ein eins wäre sozusagen
vollkommen frei von von Eitelkeit zu
seintig genaute ich übrigens nicht mal
für einen erstrebenswerten Zustand ja
weil man schnell bei der
Verwahrlosung Menschen die sagen also
Eitelkeit in jeglicher Form ist mir
fremd weiß ich nicht ob das jetzt so
positiv ja V ist es auch gelogen
also Eitelkeit kann ja wahrscheinlich in
einer guten Dosis ja auch eine gute
Sache sein ne genau das was du gerade
ansprichst man lässt sich nicht also
gibt ja gibt ja viele Formen von
Eitelkeiten finde ich immer ne ich fand
es immer interessant wenn z.B gesagt
wurde Angela Merkel wir wir mögen die
weil die so uneitel ist ja und dann
dachte ich immer
wenn ihr euch da mal nicht täuscht ich
ich kenne sie nicht so genau persönlich
aber ich bin mir sicher da gibt's
vielleicht nicht unbedingt immer so eine
äußere Eitelkeit und ich würde auch
immer sagen Angela merk ist sicher nicht
der eitelste Mensch unter dieser Sonne
aber dass Angela Merkel frei von
Eitelkeit wäre es würde glaube ich nicht
mal Angela Merkel behaupten gut
kritisiert wird ja die sichtbare also
die geckhafte die sichtbare die
inszenierte die vor sich hergetragene
Eitelkeit ja also Menschen die wie ihre
Eitelkeit wie eine Monstranz vor sich
hertragen ja wo man ST oh mein Gott ist
der eitel ja so Gigolos die so ihren
Espresso trinken und sich dabei selber
Filmen und ins Netz stellen weil sie
finden dass dieser Vorgang so so
großartig und atemberaubend ist dass man
in der Welt mitteilen sollte z da sagst
du natürlich was wichtiges wir leben in
einer Gesellschaft in der Eitelkeit ein
zentrales Geschäftsmodell geworden das
meine ich doch also die ganze Instagram
wel könnte ja und tiktokwelt kann ja
ohne Eitelkeit gar nicht bestehen
richtig Eitelkeit Hochmut das ist ja ein
das wie du sagst ein gigantisches
Geschäftsmodell geworden wobei Hochmut
ist ja ist ja noch was and gleiche ne
aber wir reden ja so über die so ein
Katalog von Sachen wo stolz auch
zugehört genau ne stolz auf sich zu sein
also also diese nazistischen
Eigenschaften bei mir ist das sehr
interessant weil also stolz war bei uns
also ich wür ums abzuschließen ich würde
mir drei geben ich will nicht ausweichen
ich würde mir glaub ich eine drei geben
vier vielleicht vielleicht bin ich
wirklich ein eitler Sack ich würde mich
ungefähr in selben Ranking sehen ja
zwischen dre und VI ja zwischen D und VI
sehr stimmungsabhängig ne es gibt
natürlich Momente wo man irgendwas
hingekriegt hat wo man man ziemlich
erfüllt von sich ist aber ich kenne ja
auch die gegenteiligen Momente ja wo man
mit sich hadert oder wo man mit sich
unzufrieden ist oder wo man sich
überhaupt nicht großartig fühlt und so
und ich meine wenn man sich da eine Sex
geben würde dann reden wir über jene
Leute die über jegliche Kritik gegenüber
sich selbst haben sind ne und ich denke
so dieser dieser Prozess der
selbstkritik ist etwas was einem bei
Tätigkeiten wie die die du machst oder
die ich mache unausgesetzt begleitet zal
man die auch unausgesetzt nicht nur
gelobt sondern auch kritisiert wird ja
viel mehr als gelobt wird man ja
kritisiert und ich ich ich habe das am
Anfang als und da kriegst du mich dann
natürlich das hat natürlich was mit
verletzter Eitelkeit dann zu tun
wenn man wenn man richtig ein geschenkt
kriegt die ganze Zeit dann ist das eine
harte Schule und man hasst das alles ähm
heute habe ich begriffen das anders zu
sehen für mich ist Kritik für mich ist
Tadel und und alles was dann so kommt am
Ende einfach nur eine Erweiterung des
Bildes wenn du so willst und ich find's
wichtig dass es das gibt und ich kann
nur sagen mir hat das gut getan das
macht einen deutlich demütiger und ich
würde auch bei dir sagen ich ich kenne
dich ja jetzt so ein bisschen privat
auch würd nicht sagen dass du ein über
alle Maßen eitler Mensch bist sondern
eher einer der viele Selbstzweifel auch
mit sich rumträgt der sich permanent
hinterfragt und und der sicher auch
eitel ist gar keine Frage deine Frisur
verrät ist aber trotzdem das mit der
Frisur ist völliger
blödsin habe ich dich jetzt habe ich
dich da muss ich jetzt ja muss mal ganz
klar sagen weil die Frisur wird gerne
alsbild meineer Eitelkeit gesehen muss
sagen diese Frisur ist so unglaublich
pflegeleicht und ich gehe auch nicht
besonders regelmäßig zum Friseur und ich
behandle meine Haare mit keinem
sondershampoo Zusatzmittel oder
irgendetwas und kämme sie mit einer
herkömmlichen Bürste Punkt also warum
die Tatsache lange Haare zu haben zum
zum Inbegriff oder zum Sinn Bild von
Eitelkeit werden kann ja weil du einfach
so cool also eine Glatze jeden Tag auf
Hochglanz zu polieren ja also ein
deutlich eitleres Werk ja als mit
längeren Haaren
rumzulaufen kommen wir auf deine deine
langen Haare stehen dir gut und das
weißt du auch und deswegen lässt du sie
natürlich auch so wachst und ist auch
völlig okay würde ich mal sagen das 99%
aller Menschen versuchen eine Frisur zu
haben die ih halbwegs steht so genau das
ist doch der Punkt und natürlich ist es
unfassbar einfach dich dann einfach auf
die auf die Haare zu reduzieren aber du
hast die Haare schon schön muss ich
sagen ich mag das das ist interessant
mal darüber nachzudenken ob sozusagen
Eitelkeit Hochmut fehlende Demut
die die die ältere Generation der jungen
gerne vorwirft ob das wirklich ein
Generation Thema ist und ob wir das
anders definiert haben und ich würde
sagen ja bescheidenheit ist keine Tugend
mit der man es heute noch zu was bringt
ja das hat sich massiv verändert in 50er
60er Jahren wurde
erwartet also Respekt vor dem Alter z.
schwer ja war immer eine wichtige
Kategorie gewesen ne und man wo hat die
Kinder ja auch dann muss man sagen war
ja umgekehrt blöd ne also alles was
junge Menschen geäußert hab sowieso
mistst weil die kannten ja nichts vom
Leben und solange die ihre Füße noch
unter den Tisch und so das will ich
nicht loben ich meine nur wir sind Ken
könn der Kuchen spricht haben die
krümelpause solche Sätze ja ja genau wir
wurden nicht ernst genommen genau genau
also früher war mistst und heute neigen
wir dazu es vielleicht in die
Gegenrichtung ein bisschen zu
übertreiben das ist eigentlich und was
geändert hat ist wir sehen halt wie wie
großsprecherische Menschen ja Elon Musk
oder Steve Jobs oder was weiß ich was
was sie auf die Beine gestellt haben den
also jede Demut und jede Bescheidenheit
fremd gewesen ist wir sehen Karrieren
die Menschen gemacht haben die perfektes
overselling betrieben haben und und und
und und und das mit all diesen
Rollenbildern wachsen junge Menschen ja
auch auf und dann zu sagen so Sätze wie
von früher schuster bleib bei deinen
Leisten oder ähm äh immer schon schön
bescheiden bleiben und so das sind die
Tugenden einer anderen Zeit das sind
nicht me die Tugenden in unserer
Gesellschaft genau und ich habe immer
gedacht und auch mit Blick auf auf die
jüngere Generation auf die auf auf die
eigenen Kinder und so weiter ist ein
schmaler Grad sozusagen zwischen
bescheiden sein demütig sein und dann
devot sein und was was unsere Eltern oft
meinten ist ihr müsst gefähllligst
gewoht sein deswegen mag ich dieses
Selbstbewusstsein dieser jungen
Generation mag ich sehr und auch und da
müssen wir uns sozusagen auch
selbstdisziplinieren dass wir nicht
diese diese diese Selbstbewusstsein dass
die haben mit Hochmut Eitelkeit und
Selbstüberschätzung verwechseln weil das
sind die häufig nicht aber sie sind
selbstbewusst und das mag ich das ist
gut das eine andere Art des Leben zu
sehen deswegen sagst hast du völlig
recht wenn du sagst ist eine andere Zeit
also wenn man jung ist gibt's ein Recht
auf Selbstüberschätzung auch das weil
man muss sich ja ausprobieren ja und
woher soll man eigentlich wissen wie
reif schlau und ausgewogen das was man
sagt ist wenn man sich seine Hörner
nicht abstürßt und das Schöne ist dass
wir heute in einer Gesellschaft leben wo
man das darf ja was heißt du du darfst
das
weil du als junger Mensch heute ernster
genommen wirst als du früher genommen
worden bist und das finde ich absolut
gut und sich selbst zu überschätzen oder
sich falsch einzuschätzen seine Kräfte
geistiger und körperliche Art falsch
einzuschätzen ist etwas völlig normales
für junge Menschen aus denen man lernt
und an den man reift und dass das heute
alles möglich ist ist ein unglaublicher
Vorteil gegenüber früher ja was übrigens
weil wir gerade über junge Leute
sprechen super Übergang zu Zorn und Wut
auch so eine Todsünde ja und ich erlebe
genau das und wahrscheinlich speist sich
das auch aus diesem Selbstbewusstsein
dass sie mitbringen das ist eine häufig
wütende eine zornige Generation und auch
da würde ich sagen Wut ist in bei meiner
Generation etwas zornig zu sein weil
etwas das war das war sozial nicht
erwünscht heute würde ich sagen Wut kann
eine wahnsinnig gute Energie und gute
Kraft sein ja die Frage ist immer wie
man es macht in welchem Maß zur
richtigen Zeit zum richtigen Zweck aber
Wut ist erstmal auch eine irrsinnige
Energie ja ich würde aber sagen das was
du sagst beschreibt die eine Hälfte auf
der anderen Hälfte ist genau umgekehrt
also früher wurde sich auf dem Schulhof
unter Jungens nicht selten sondern hofft
sehr Regel
geprügelt das war nichts was erwünscht
war das zeitigte aber auch keine
dramatischen Konsequenzen ja weil diese
meisten prügelein waren ja spaßkämpfchen
ne wo man seine Kraft miteinander
gemessen hat und wir nm Wehen den
Schwitzkasten und so genau so und das
war das war nicht erlaubt aber es wurde
auch nicht schwer
bestraft heute in der Grundschule ja so
wie das war als mein Sohn in der
Grundschule war oder sowas also sich zu
prügeln das ging gar nicht ja das gab
natürlich war das eine riesen auf F der
dann betrieben wurde und Eltern in die
Schule und Beratungsgespräche und fünf
Lehrer dabei und am besten noch ein
Psychologe und und und das heißt also
diese Art von von rauslassen von
Aggressionen oder sowas ist heute
überhaupt nicht mehr gestattet ich habe
dann bei der Schule angeregt ob man
nicht tobräume einführen können dass man
dann wenigstens in den Pausen dann nicht
einfach nur blöd auf dem Hof steht
sondern dass man dann so trampolinräume
tobmatten oder irgendwas hat wo man sich
irgendwie balgen und Raufen kann unter
Aufsicht weil diese ganze ang der
Energie ja raus muss mm das hat man sich
dann in der Schule da alles brav
angehört ich habe auch gesagt ich wä
bereit den tobraum zu stiften und zu
finanzieren aber Idee ist da nicht
weiter verfolgt worden worauf ich hinaus
will ist dies die auf dieser Ebene ja
Junge sein ja zuud dem eben dann auch
gehört dass man Aggressionen hat ne weil
Testosteron da einschießt und so und da
muss man sich halt Formen überlegen wie
man damit umgehen kann aber es reicht
nicht zu sagen du darfst das nicht und
du sollst das nicht ja weil dann bleibt
das ja alles in einem drin und kocht und
schmurt und so weiter weiter da sind wir
überhaupt nicht gut mit Wut oder mit
Zorn oder mit Aggression umzugehen also
was du sagst es es heute stadthafter ist
vielleicht ist es stadthafter auf der
Ebene die Du beschrieben hast aber auf
der unmittelbaren körperlichen Ebene ist
es heute viel weniger stadthaft als
früher und auch hier würde ich nicht
sagen es war früher besser als heute ich
würde wieder sagen wir sind von einem
Extrem ins andere gegangen mhm das ist
wahr ich meine ein ich gehö nicht zu den
Leuten die die ständig den dal Lama
zitieren aber der Satz ist gut wenn wir
uns von Wut beherrschen lassen geht uns
das höchste Vermögen unserer Intelligenz
verloren nämlich die
Urteilskraft und das ist natürlich etwas
wo du sagst um das geht genau jetzt auf
die auf die Weltlage ja wenn du siehst
was was gerade im Nahen Osten
beispielsweise passiert mein das ist
doch ein wirklich guter Satz ich Ken den
Satz aus dem Paten aus dem Paten ja da
sagt der Pater im ersten Band man sollte
seine Feinde nicht hassen ja das trübt
das Urteilsvermögen ich weiß jetzt nicht
ob es der Dalai Lama aus smpaten hat
oder der Mario puo vom Dalai Lama aber
das würde ich gerne mal wissen ich bin
mir sicher der dal Lama hat vom Paten
ich mir glaub ich ehrlich gesagt
auch ich glaub dem dama ist nichts
weltliches fremd und so auch der PTE
nicht aber der Gedanke ist natürlich
unheimlich gut dahinter ne sich nicht
von seiner Wut leiten zu lassen wenn du
überlegst wo gerade Wut und und sousagen
das Gefühl Rache nehmen zu wollen und
auch zu müssen wo das gerade überall auf
der Welt getriggert wird von der Ukraine
über Israel über Gaza überall hast du
genau das ist genau das Gefühl das
gerade angestachelt wird wie wenige
andere und dann die Frage wie gehst du
damit um ja sehr sehr schwierig weil wir
leben ja heute in einer Zeit in der
Emotionen ja einen anderen Stellenwert
haben ich habe das ja schon häufig
gesagt als in allen Gesellschaften zuvor
ne also wie man sich fühlt und was man
denkt weil man sich in der bestimmten
Art und Weise fühlt ist heute ja
gesellschaftlich legitimiert ja ich
fühle mich nicht danach ja und auch wenn
Journalisten Politikern Frage stellen
geht's immer darum wie fühlen Sie sich
wie haben Sie sich gefühlt als Sie in
diesem Moment und so es geht nur noch um
Gefühle mhm und das ist natürlich klar
dass auch die negativen Gefühle ein Teil
unseres äh verhaltensrepertoirs sind und
dass die dass die aufflammen und dass
wir natürlich diese Gefühle auch für
legitim halten dass sie aufflammen aber
es sind ja zwei verschiedene Dinge das
eine sind ist die Legitimität solcher
Gefühle es gibt gar keine illegitimen
Gefühle ne Gefühle hat man ob man will
oder nicht und das andere ist eben wie
man sie kanalisiert wie man damit umgeht
welche Lösungen man dafür findet und ich
meine da hat natürlich niemand
Patentlösungen schon gar nicht in diesen
beiden äh gewaltigen äh furchtbaren
Schauplätzen von denen du gerade
gesprochen hast mhm welche Todsünde
haben wir noch übrig auf föllerei
essen ja ich ich habere zah
Gelen dribbelk das ist nicht die
schlechteste Form von föllere die
rudöllereöllerei ja wobei auch ein gutes
Beispiel für Zorn also der die
legendäre Spuckattacke und der Föller
mit dem knallroot hochen Kopf der geht
auch zu den unvertauschbaren
glanzbildern meiner Sozialisation also
das hollanddeutschland Spiel im
Achtelfinale
1990 Rudi Föller im im Nahkampf mit
Waldi Hartmann ne oh ja das als als
Teamchef rich rich du sit hier mit dein
hast schon deine drei Weizen drei Weizen
drei Weizen getrunken ja genau richtig
legendär ja und und ausgeteilt gegen
Günther n ja der NS zu der ja hier
nichts zu motzen hätte weil er nur
Standfußball gespielt
hätte genau und und da
haten haben ih total angegriffen aber
die Menschen waren so dermaßen auf
seiner Seite weil die das F die fanden
das so natürlich und so menschlich dass
da auch mal einer die kenance verliert
und der darf das doch auch also ich muss
sagen ob es jetzt inhaltlich gut oder
schlecht war weiß ich nicht aber ich war
emotional auf Völlers Seite ich finde
man darf auch mal wütend werden ja und
ich meine nicht zu vergessen diese Wut
diese dieser Wutausbruch von von Rudi
Föller hat ja zu einem legendär guten
Werbevertrag für waldemar Hartmann
geführt also am Ende hat hat diese diese
diese Wut dieser Tobsuchtsanfall war der
W nicht nur ein Ventil sportlich für
Rudi Föller sondern auch die Rente für
baldim hartmann ist doch super ja da
kann man mal sehen wo zuu Zorn führen
kan liebe Grüße übrigens an der Stelle
genau ja also bei föllerei föllerei ist
natürlich heute irgendwie nur noch eine
indirekte Todsünde weil das Essen selber
nicht mehr verteufelt wird sondern
verteufelt wird das dick seinm ich meine
jetzt inzwischen auch nicht mehr ganz ne
heute haben wir so ein
enentes Verhältnis dazu im Zeitalter der
curvy Models und so weiter trotzdem ist
es ja immer noch so dass in vielen
vielen Menschen sagt da lässt sich
jemand gehen da hat jemand keine
Disziplin da macht nicht jemand genug
Sport da ist jemand zu viel das ist
natürlich alles noch in den Köpfen der
Menschen drin aber merkwürdigerweise die
Tätigkeit selber dass man also sich den
den kulinarischen Genüssen bedingungslos
hingibt das wird eigentlich nicht mehr
verteufelt sondern nur eher die Folge
falls man davon die werden sollte ja ja
da da ist aber viel Widersprüchlichkeit
drin ne und das ist auch eine direkte
Linie hin zu Eitelkeit ja die dann das
das Geschäftsmodell geworden ist also äh
ich sag mal äh die die Kontrolle über
Essen die Kontrolle über jede einzelne
Kalorie und so weiter der der perfekte
Körper der erstrebenswert erscheint ich
ich ich finde da sind wir als
Gesellschaft irgendwie schon auf einer
schiefen Bahn unterwegs da lauert glaube
ich vieles und das letzte Richard
Wollust ja ja Oscar wild wenig
überraschend schöner Satz die beste Art
und Weise eine Versuchung loszuwerden
ist ihr Nacht zugeben ja fin ich gut ja
dann tyrannisiert sie dich nicht weiter
das stimmt lass Geschehen genau
interessant ist wollllust ne also geht
um Sex ne um es mal deutlich zu sagen
ist auch so schöne Wörter ne Wollust
Völlerei also die die die Sprache
erzählt viel über die Zeit aus der das
alles stammt das stammt beides aus der
Zeit in der dass die Hingabe an das
sinnliche in eine unmittelbare direkte
Konkurrenz zur Macht der K getreten ist
denn da ist es ja nicht die Hingabe an
das sinnliche da ist die Hingabe an das
geistige an das
spirituelle die Hingabe an das sinnliche
lenkt von der Hingabe an das spirituelle
ab ne also der der das eigentliche ideal
ist ja der Asket der sein Leben Gott
widmet und der sich eben nicht
weltlichen Gelüsten hingibt und die sind
nun bekanntermaßen sehr sehr
verführerisch und deswegen müssen die
bekämpft werden es geht darum wer hat
die Kontrolle über den Leib ja die
Kirche die Kontrolle oder hat man die
Kontrolle selber das ist genau der Punkt
wer die Sexualität kontrolliert
kontrolliert den ganzen Menschen und das
haben Religionen sehr früh verstanden
das haben sie sehr früh verstanden wei
Sie was die Kontrolle der Sexualität
anbelangt am Anfang auch sehr gute
Gründe hatten es zu tun es ist doch
interessant die diese die Gedanke dass
man monogam leben sollte mit einem
Partner und mit anderen Partnern keinen
Sex haben da ging es nicht nur um
Kontrolle am Anfang
sondern da ging es um zwei ganz ganz
wichtige Dinge das eine war
Gesundheit ja das Ausbreiten von solchen
zu verhindern also wenn die Menschen
sich wild untereinander Vergnügen dann
ist der Weitergabe von allen
erdenklichen Infektionskrankheiten Tür
und Tor geöffnet man denke mal an
Hepatitis z.B wo wusste man ja natürlich
nicht Hepatitis B ne bis heute eine der
der der größten äh Geißeln der
Menschheit die über Geschlechtsverkehr
weitergegeben werden ne auch
Geschlechtskrankheiten und vieles andere
mehr gegen die man ja damals gar keine
Mittel hatte die es aber all schon gab
deswegen war das sozusagen im Sinne von
unter Hygiene Gesichtspunkten eingebot
das ist der eine Punkt der zweite Punkt
war das Erbrecht wenn man sich mit allen
erdenklichen Frauen vergnügt und Frauen
mit allen erdenklichen Männern dann weiß
man im Zweifel zwar nicht von wem die
Kinder sind und da stellt sich nachher
die wichtige Frage wer erbt die Schafe
ja und um das ein für alle mal so
gründlich wie möglich zu regeln weil die
Religion war ja für die gesamten
juristischen Fragen zuständig war ja für
alles zuständig für Gesundheit wie für
juristischen Fragen ist natürlich das
Beste was passieren kann ist enthaltsame
gegenüber anderen Partnern Monogamie ja
weil dann sind all diese Sachen ganz
säuberlich und ganz ganz klar geregelt
also das sind z.B zwei starke rationale
Argumente warum Religion sich in die
Sexualität der Menschen eingemischt hat
interessant ist ja was da
gesellschaftlich stattgefunden hat auch
in der philosop ie aber letzten Endes
glaube ich auch in der Kirche also
Wollust ist heute keine Todsünde mehr
das ist eigentlich der Punkt und ich
finde es so gut dass dieses Gefühl dass
Sexualität etwas ganz verbotenes etwas
Schlimmes ist etwas was man ganz
heimlich und und so weiter und keiner
darf irgendwie bloß mitkriegen ja auf
die Frage wie den die ganzen Kinder
zustande gekommen sind ja und die waren
sehr zahlreich auch früher bei uns in
den Bergen da hat nie eine richtige
Antwort gegeben kannst du dich an die
Antworten erinnern
nee aber es war klar das war mit einem
starken tabubeleg da das war wahnsinnig
tabuisiert und ich bin wirklich froh
darüber dass das vorbei ist und
interessanterweise hat's ja nicht zu dem
geführt was damals immer befürchtet
wurde ja das gottlose komplett
lasterhafte Leben und die wschen
Menschen werden nur noch also im Grunde
ihre Zeit mit mit dem Feiern von Orgien
verbringen so ist es ja gar nicht es ist
ja das genaue Gegenteil eingetreten wenn
du dir junge Menschen heute anguckst die
die Glauben wieder sehr an an an an
lebenslange Treue an die große Liebe an
Partnerschaft und so weiter frü Kinder
ja das ist und das meine ich und das
zeigt halt eben wenn du Dinge nicht so
taboisierst ja dann dann lass den Ding
in ihren Lauf und dann ist alles gut und
das ist wirklich eine gute Entwicklung
weil das war früher katastrophal dem
gibt's nichts hinzuzufügen ich wollte
zum Schluss Richard noch auf etwas
kommen was ich interessant fand
mahatmandi sozagen die moralische
Instanz ja wenn du über über Sünden
sprichst ist so der der Inbegriff des
guten Menschen ja neben dem dal Lama
wahrscheinlich der hat was anderes
gemacht der hat eine Liste der sieben
sozialen Sünden irgendwann mal erstellt
ich trag mal kurz vor Politik ohne
Prinzipien Reichtum ohne Arbeit
Vergnügen ohne
Gewissen wissen ohne Charakter Geschäft
ohne Moral Wissenschaft ohne
Menschlichkeit und Religion ohne Opfer
mhm
das letzte das letzte verstört auf dem
ersten Blick oder ja was ist mit Opfer
gemeint also mit mit mit mit mit
Verzicht oder ist mit Opfer Tat
Opferritual kann ja nicht gemeint sein
ich müsste es interpretieren ja hat
magandi als als Hindu kann ich mir jetzt
nicht wirklich vorstellen dass das für
ihn eine solche existenzielle Bedeutung
hatte ohne Opfer wäre doch
wahrscheinlich also religiös zu sein
ohne sich
deswegen gewisse Selbstverpflichtungen
aufzulegen also so würde ich das jetzt
mal interpretieren also eine Religion
die ein nichts kostet weil man auf
nichts verzichten muss sozusagen we man
genauso weiterleben kann wie bisher also
so würde ich den Satz mal interpretieren
ja ja aber ansonsten ist das natürlich
äh deutlich vorbildlicher für die
heutige Zeit als die Todsünden über die
wir uns unterhalten haben ne also ja so
Politik ohne Prinzipien ist kann man
sofort
unterschreiben Arbeit se interessant ja
Reichtum ohne Arbeit das ist das reicht
Arbeit gibt es natürlich dadurch viel
das viel vererbt wird ja ne ob das jetzt
eine Todsünde ist darüber kann man
länger streiten das sieht die FDP dann
sicherlich anders als
ich möglicherweise ja genau ja also in
jedem Fall finde ich diese sieben
sozialen Sünden von Gandi die sind top
aktuell das ist eine Liste 1925
veröffentlicht und
das versteht man auch so hat es auch
damals veröffentlicht ohne weiteren
Kommentar deswegen ist Religion oh eine
Opfer ist auch nicht so richtig klar was
er damit meint aber den Rest versteht
man sehr sehr gut und ich finde das ist
eine gute Handlungsanleitung nicht nur
fürs Leben sondern auch für die Art und
Weise wie wir zusammenleben definieren
das stimmt so kann man über die
mittelalterlichen Todsünden zu einem
sehr modernen tugendkatalog kommen genau
richard hat Spaß gemacht viel über dich
erfahren ja leider nicht ganz so viel
über dich ich bin ganz sicher es wird
bemängelt werden dass wir die Note für
Wollust bei dir nicht erfahren hab ja
das machen wir dann beim nächsten Mal
und in diesem Sinne ein vergnügliches
Wochenende ich danke dir bis dann
tschüss alles Liebe tschüss
Markus eine Produktion von mhoch2 und
podstars bei OMR im Auftrag des
ZDF